.
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG TO THE
KICKING BACK IN THE CLASS
EVERYBODY LOOKED FORWARD TO THE
DRAMA CLUB NEXT BRAD PITT.
DEBATE CLUB PEOPLE ASPIRING TO
BE THE NEXT SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE.
BUT, I WASN'T REALLY A CLUB GUY.
>> THE NEXT SCREW THAT FALLS OUT
IS GOING TO BE YOU.
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> EAT MY SHORTS.
>> WHATEVER CLUB IT WAS TO MAKE
YOU A BETTER PERSON.
MAKE FRIENDS, EXPAND YOUR
HORIZONS.
TODAY A NEW PROGRAM TRYING TO
TAKE HOLD IN OUR SCHOOLS.
SATAN CLUBS.
ONE VIRGINIA TOWN IS ALREADY
SEEING IT FIRSTHAND.
B.M. WILLIAMS PRIMARY SCHOOL
INTRODUCED THE AFTER SCHOOL
SATAN CLUB ORGANIZED BY THE
SATANIC TEMPLE.
THE CLUB PROMOTES ACTIVITIES
AROUND THE SEVEN TENETS OF
SATANISM.
EQUIVALENT OF THE 10
COMMANDMENTS.
THIS OBVIOUSLY HAS
UPSET PARENTS.
ONE MOM SPOKE TO FOX, WATCH.
>> THIS WAS WHEN PARENTS TRULY
SHOWED UP.
HAD A RECORD TURNOUT.
PARENTS IN OPPOSITION WERE THE
MAJORITY TURNOUT.
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY TURNOUT.
WHEN WE'RE DISCUSSING SATAN
CLUBS IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS, WE
ARE FAILING OUR CHILDREN.
WE ARE FAILING OUR CHILDREN.
THESE ARE FRIGHTENING IMAGES.
THIS IS A FRIGHTENING IDEOLOGY.
IT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
ADULTS IN THE ROOM TO STAND UP
AND SPEAK UP FOR THE PARENTS.
WE HAVE TO DO BETTER.
>> Jesse: I GET IT.
WE DON'T WANT SATAN BEING
PROMOTED TO OUR CHILDREN.
"PRIMETIME" HAS BEEN COVERING
THESE SATANISTS FOR A WHILE.
A FEW MONTHS AGO, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU REMEMBER.
WE WENT TO SATAN CON TO FIND OUT
WHAT THESE PEOPLE ARE ALL ABOUT.
>>
>> SATAN REPRESENTS CARNAL
DESIRE.
>> WHAT DOES SATAN LOOK LIKE?
>> ME.
>> SATAN LOOKS LIKE WHATEVER YOU
WANT SATAN TO LOOK LIKE IN YOUR
MIND.
>> THE BIGGEST MISCONCEPTION
ABOUT SATANISM IS THAT WE
SACRIFICE CHILDREN.
WE EAT BABIES.
AND WE DON'T LIKE KITTENS.
AND THIS COULD BE THE FARTHEST
FROM THE TRUTH.
WE LOVE KITTENS.
WE LOVE BABIES.
>> Jesse: OH, SO THEY LIKE
KITTENS.
WHAT ELSE ARE THEY ABOUT?
WELL, WE STILL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS.
LET'S ASK THE SATANIC TEMPLE
SPOKESPERSON LUCIENIAN GRIEVES.
ALL RIGHT.
>> GOOD TO MEET YOU.
>> Jesse: NICE MEET YOU, TOO.
IF SATAN IS EVIL, WHY SHOULD KID
BE IN AN EVIL CLUB?
>> OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T VIEW SATAN
AS EVIL.
AND IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER TO
US WHAT YOUR MYTHOLOGY IS
SURROUNDING SATAN.
YOU NEED TO ASK YOURSELF IF YOUR
DISTASTE OVER US IDENTIFYING
IDENTIFYING ASSATANIST YOU WOULE
SPEECH AND RELIGIOUS LIBERTY.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT SATAN WAS
LIKE SEX.
WHEN YOU ARE 18, SATAN, SEX, DO
YOUR THING.
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD WANT
SATAN IN SCHOOLS.
YOU UNDERSTAND HOW PARENTS FEEL,
RIGHT?
>> WELL, PARENTS CAN FEEL THAT
WAY AND MANY PARENTS FEEL
SIMILARLY ABOUT EVANGELICAL
AFTER SCHOOL CLUB IN FACT PUT
OUR CLUB IN PLACE TO OFFER IT
ALTERNATIVE TO EVANGELICAL CLUB
CONVERT CHILDREN TO GET THEM TO
PARKING LOT WILL HE ADVERTISE TO
OTHER KIDS.
IF PARENT DON'T WANT THEM SEND
THEIR KIDS TO AFTER SCHOOL
SATAN.
CLUB.
THERE IS OTHER RELIGIOUS CLUB.
REALLY THE CONTROVERSY EVADES
THE ISSUE AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE WILLING TO ALLOW
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONARIES AT
SCHOOL BOARDS OR WHATEVER TO
SIMPLY SHUT DOWN SOMEBODY'S
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY OR FREE SPEECH
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE IT.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE DOING IT TO
TWEAK THE SYSTEM.
I GET IT.
WHAT ARE THESE TENETS OF
SATANISM?
CAN YOU ENLIGHTEN ME?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THE TENETS ARE VERY
PRO-SOCIAL.
THEY'RE ALMOST UNIVERSAL, I
WOULD THINK.
I THINK AS TIME GOES ON WE WILL
KIND OF CONVERGE ON A CONSENSUS
MORE RATTLE.
BUT AS -- BUT WE DON'T HAVE.
TO SAY I MEAN, WE ARE NOT
LOOKING TO CONVERT PEOPLE INTO
SATANISM.
WE ARE NOT EVEN TEACHING
CHILDREN ABOUT SATANISM IN THE
CLASSES.
>> Jesse: GIVE ME A TENET.
>> ONE SHOULD STRIVE TO ACT WITH
COME TAGS AND EMPATHY TO ALL
CREATURES WITHIN REASON.
>> Jesse: OH.
THAT SOUNDS FINE.
ALL RIGHT.
>> YOU MIGHT LIKE IT.
>> Jesse: MAYBE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT ALL OF THAT.
ARE YOU MARRIED BY THE WAY?
>> NO.
I'M NOT.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
I WAS JUST WONDERING.
ALL RIGHT.
SO YOU ARE PROBABLY GOING TO GO
TO HELL, RIGHT?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IN HELL.
WE'RE NOT A NON-THEOSTIC.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT MANE YOU
WANTED TO GO TO HELL.
>> SOUNDS LIKE A BETTER PARTY
THAN HEAVEN.
ALL THE PARTY WHERE ALL THE
SEXLESS GO AFTER THEY LEIF
CELIBATE UNINTERESTING LIFE.
HELL MIGHT BE OKAY.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT TO GO.
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO BUTCHER
YOUR NAME AGAIN.
LUCIEN.
>> THAT'S OKAY IT'S LUCIEN
GRIEVES.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU